as we start to graph lines we might
notice that there are differences
between lines for example this pink or
this magenta line here it looks steeper
than this blue line
and what we'll see is this notion of
steepness how steep a line is how
quickly does it increase or how quickly
does it decrease is a really useful idea
in mathematics so ideally we'd be able
to put assign a number to each of these
lines or to any line that describes how
steep it is how how quickly does it
increase or decrease so what's a
reasonable way to do that what's a
reasonable way to assign a number to
these lines that describe their
steepness
well one way to think about it could say
well how much how much does a line
increase for how much does a line
increase in the vertical direction for a
given increase in the horizontal
direction so let's write this down so
let's say if we
an increase
increase
in vertical
for a given increase in horizontal
for a given increase
given increase
in horizontal
so how how could this give us how could
this give us a value well let's look at
that let's look at that magenta line
again and let's just start at an
arbitrary point of that magenta line but
i'll start at a point where it's going
to be easy for me to figure out what
point we're at
so if we were to start right here
and if i were to increase in the
horizontal direction
by one so i move one to the right to get
back on the line how much do i have to
increase in the vertical direction well
i have to increase in the vertical
direction by 2
by 2. so at least for this magenta line
it looks like our increase in vertical
is 2 whenever we have an increase in 1
in the horizontal direction
and we could let's see does that apply
let's see does that still work if i were
to go if i were to start here instead of
increasing the horizontal direction by
1. if i were to increase in the
horizontal direction so let's increase
by three
so now i've gone plus three in the
horizontal direction then to get back on
the line how much do i have to increase
in the vertical direction i have to
increase by one two three four five six
i have to increase by six
so plus six
so when i increase by
three in
the horizontal direction i increase by
six in the vertical we're just saying
hey let's just measure how much we
increase in vertical for a given
increase in horizontal well 2 over 1 is
just 2 and that's the same thing as 6
over 3.
so no matter where i start on this line
no matter where i start on this line
if i take and if i increase in the
horizontal direction
by a given amount i'm going to increase
twice as much
in
the vertical direction twice as much in
the vertical direction so this notion of
increase in vertical divided by increase
in horizontal this is what
mathematicians use to describe the
steepness of lines and this is called
the slope
so this is called the slope of a line
and you're probably familiar with the
notion of the word slope being used for
say a key a ski slope and that's because
a ski slope has a certain inclination it
could have a steep slope or a shallow
slope so slope is a measure for how
steep something is and the convention is
is we measure the increase in vertical
for a given increase in horizontal
so six two over one is equal to six over
three is equal to two this is equal to
the slope of this magenta line so slope
so let me write this down
so this slope right over here
the slope of that line is going to be
equal to 2.
and one way to interpret that if you for
whatever amount you increase in the
horizontal direction you're going to
increase twice as much in the vertical
direction
now what about this blue line here what
would be the slope of the blue line well
let me rewrite another way that you'll
you'll typically see the definition of
slope and this is just the convention
that mathematicians have defined for
slope but it's a valuable one what is
our change in vertical for a given
change in horizontal and i'll introduce
a new notation for you so
change in vertical
and in this coordinate it's going to be
the vertical is our y coordinate divided
by our change in horizontal and x is our
horizontal coordinate in this in this x
and this coordinate plane right over
here and you might say wait you said
change in but then you drew this
triangle
well this triangle this is the greek
letter delta
this is the greek letter delta and it's
a math symbol used to represent change
in so that's delta
delta
and it literally means change in y
change in y
divided by change in x
change
in x so if we want to find the slope of
the blue line
we just have to say well how much does y
change for given change in x
so the slope of the blue line
so let's see
let's see actually let me do this let me
do it this way
let me have a
when if i let's just start at some point
here
and let's say if my x changes by 2
so my delta x is equal to positive 2
what's my delta y going to be what's
going to be my change in y
well if i go to the right by two to get
back on the line i have to increase my y
by two so my change
in y is also going to be plus two so the
slope of this blue line
the slope of the blue line
which is change in y over change in x
we just saw that when our change in x is
positive 2 our change in y is also
positive 2. so our slope is 2 divided by
2 which is equal to 1 which tells us
however much we increase in x we're
going to increase that same amount in y
and you see that you increase 1 and x
you increase 1 and y increase 1 and x
increase 1 and y from any point on the
line that's going to be true you
increase 3 and x
you're going to increase 3 in y it's
actually true the other way if you
decrease 1 in x you're going to decrease
1 and y
if you decrease 2 and x you're going to
decrease 2 and y
and that makes sense from from the the
math of it as well because if your
change in x is negative two that's what
we did right over here we change our
change in x was negative two we went two
back then your change in y is going to
be negative two as well
your change in y is going to be negative
2 and negative 2 divided by negative 2
is positive 1 which is your slope again